all right welcome back to las vegas now
you've worked hard this week right you
deserve a weekend brunch that feeds your
soul and your belly bruce calman is here
to tell us more about sundays at soul
belly barbecue
sunday monday
okay so everybody's brunch experience is
different for sure what's the experience
you want people to walk out of soul
belly you know i think the thing is that
we've found is when we do special events
people come they want the barbecue so we
don't we don't get rid of the barbecue
we run some specials so brunch like
specials like brisket hash and eggs okay
well then i'm gonna show you how to make
this sandwich this is actually something
one of my cooks made for family meal one
day
we call it the monty briscoe the mommy
it's like our plan of monte cristo yeah
so we've got mayo and mustard if you
want to squirt a little bit yellow
mustard it gives it a nice tartness
because it's kind of a well not kind of
it's a really rich sandwich right um i
like your technique that's very that's
pretty awesome yeah i usually go zigzag
i don't go circles but i like that i
gotta stay true to me
you gotta do you
so then this is just a mix of i like
mayonnaise okay yeah we're gonna put
slices of cheddar
and if that's not enough we're gonna put
this mixture of chopped brisket and chop
more chopped cheddar oh my gosh on here
we're gonna be full this is like an
animal marshall but wait there's more
wait there's more and then i've got a
hot pan with some whole butter in it
okay and we're going to dip it in some
egg
okay
so the bread is almost like french
toasty kind of exactly
see that yeah
what's special about you guys is you're
mixing the barbecue with the breakfast
exactly yeah we just do a few you know
we'll run a few uh specials we have this
we call it the bad eight
two money signs oh uh-huh
bloody mary um it has you know pickles
and olives and
cheddar cheese and then we can also
throw them there like a whole rib or
slice a brisket oh make it a meal it's
really drinks or meals too yeah for sure
so this is kind of like the vegetarian
version and then we do the meat version
as well amazing amazing we also have a
band from twelve to three and it changes
sometimes we have a really killer blues
band uh this girl paige overton comes
plays a lot and she's fantastic so you
know it's just a fun
vibrant you know atmosphere it's really
great yeah in the arts district so
why does that make you guys extra
special too it's kind of like a vibe
outside and inside yeah it is and it is
booming right now you know we have we
are on the front of our restaurant is
all pocket doors so it all opens wide up
onto our patio and we've got our smokers
out there so the smell comes into the
restaurant you know
so
so for the sandwich we're just going to
kind of griddle it both sides i wouldn't
have enough time to really make it so
that's the tv magic the tv magic so uh
would you suggest that i go ahead and
take a bite into that i think you should
all right and so you know while you must
go to the restaurant and experience the
restaurant itself you guys also do take
out delivery all of that oh yeah we do
take out delivery we're on over eight
yeah i like your style you need to come
in and eat the soul by them
[Laughter]
but we also we started doing this killer
concert series and you're not even
hearing what i'm saying
yeah that's fine okay cool i'll just
tell them wow yeah tell them we have
this killer concert series now that
we're doing at night and uh we've got
some ticketed concerts with some
promoters that are bringing in national
acts and it's it's really fantastic we
just had uh george pacon from the black
eyed peas he has a band called cairo
knight fight and they played there last
week and it's just a great time okay so
how can people come down should they
make reservations just we don't take
reservations on the part of your ten or
more concerts it's ticketed so you have
to you know but we don't have to buy a
ticket online but it's it's recommended
okay for sure yeah didn't hear that i
was taking a bite that's okay i'm sure
it was great information yeah they heard
it
so good you guys have to try it slow
belly barbecue arch district
jc i was going to do you
send me some of that food
it's a mouthful